so a fourth booster being given out is
that because the third booster the
efficacy of that jab declines pretty
quickly
not really and we don't know yet in a
full extent
you have to remember that we started to
vaccinate 60s and above the end of july
so we are reaching now six months from
the third dose
we do not have clear data yet but it
seems that there is a benefit of giving
a force those
including uh now with when we are
tackling the omicron it will give it to
this point only for the elderly
population of for a medical personnel
actually a preliminary decision was done
yesterday but it would take a few more
days to go through all the regulatory
steps until we practically start
and is the the fourth booster exactly
the same injection as the third booster
that would be the same will give again a
physical biotech which around 95 or more
percent of our population were
vaccinated with
i think in the future we would have to
learn better about combination and there
are some signs that combining different
types of vaccine may be beneficial we
don't have yet clear data for that so at
this point we will stick to the same
regiment as we did till now
now forgive my ignorance
but is having four vaccines within 12
months perfectly fine perfectly safe no
issues with that
of course we have to test this issue and
and it's a complicated a
topic for all of us professionals the
general public and we could say after uh
having a very meticulous study of the
third dose it seems to be perfectly safe
we have some signs that the fourth dose
is safe as well we took some measures
and we have now running these days a a
study in israel of 2000 individuals
receiving the fourth dose and
by
getting the final result we would make a
final decision
there'll be a lot of people uh watching
this thinking you know i've had my first
two jabs i then had a booster i've had a
flu vaccination as well i now could be
looking at a fourth uh uh kovid jab
where when does this all all end you
know are we looking at a fifth sixth
seventh down the line
well i hope we'll end where we are with
the flow jobs meaning that every autumn
we get as a we get an injection maybe we
will be even it would be even available
to combine these two injection to one
and that will be part of the autumn
regiment of flu jobs i do understand all
of us understand that giving a shot
every six months is a huge burden both
for us as systems and certainly for the
public so the basic idea hopefully in
the future would be to be able to
combine it with the flu job now it is a
pandemic and pandemics end we can't say
if it would end in the coming year may
may take a bit longer but certainly in a
point we would go into a kind of a
routine endemic situation exactly as we
have with say influenza virus
are you getting any uh vaccine fatigue
uh from residents of israel people who
are saying look i've just had enough of
this i've had enough injections i've had
enough of the jabs i'm not going to go
for a fourth
that's certainly going to be a
phenomenon we
the majority of people who receive two
jobs got the third one
still there's a sub a population of
people that had
adverse events or inconveniences we said
of the two first jobs and decided not to
get on third one and are not now boosted
a
fatigue of injection is certainly a
thing that would happen
so as i have mentioned i do believe that
we would have to find a way how to be in
a regiment of giving a booster not more
than once a year
i noticed that in israel the first
patient with omicron to die
uh was a man in his 60s who suffered
from a number of uh serious pre-existing
conditions um
i mean is there a chance that we're
overreacting about omicron
always is a chance the problem is that
when you are not only giving
commentaries in in studios or other you
need to take decisions as a government
you are extending
the uncertainty and you have to decide
now god
hopefully
god forbid it will be differently but
hopefully it is going to be i would say
a variant with not an excessive amount
of severe and immortality cases etc
there are some signs for that but it's
too early to say and we have to take
measure to avoid what you see now in
some countries including in the uk this
massive massive spread of the new
variant and i think it's a bit too early
to say that it is
not a big deal most probably it's only i
would say a mild form of of this disease
and if so even so we would still see a
surge in hospital due to the fact that
we are dealing with huge number of new
cases
yeah a lot of debate as i'm sure you've
been following here in the uk about
whether we should bring in further
restrictions after christmas given
israel's experience
where would you say we're heading here
in the uk
well we are at the same boat all of us
and we are sharing data and
with our
british colleagues almost on a weekly
basis
and i think you are somehow exceeding us
in the wave of the omicron we'll see
what is going to happen in the uk in the
next two weeks and that would influence
a lot our own decisions
it would be the same in most european
countries i think at least the main
countries in the continent are going to
suffer from a massive wave of omicron
and we will learn much more in the next
10 to 20 days
yeah we're very much in that sort of
sort of watch and wait period aren't we
uh dr ashes allman deputy director
general of the israeli health ministry
thank you very much indeed your time
it's much appreciated thank you